How do other languages accommodate non-binary people?
In the English-speaking world they and them...
...are by far the most common pronouns for non-binary people...
...but other languages don’t all have it quite so easy
Around a third of the world’s languages use grammatical gender...
...in which nouns are typically sorted into male and female...
...or masculine and feminine. For example...
...in French "la table"—the table—is feminine...
...and in German "der schlüssel"—the key—is masculine
But languages with grammatical gender pose a problem...
...for those who don’t identify as male or female...
...so they are coming up with some innovative solutions
Spanish is one language where activists...
...have come up with a fairly elegant solution
The use of the ending -e on nouns and adjectives...
...rather than the usual -o for masculine and -a for feminine
And the pronoun “elle” has been invented...
... to be the equivalent of Spanish’s they or them...
...for non-binary people...
...because it closely resembles both “él” for he...
...and “ella” for she
And in Swedish...
...the pronoun “hen” is gaining ground...
...as a neat compromise in pronunciation...
...between "han" for he, and "hon" for she
But some languages are easier to tweak...
...to accommodate non-binary people than others
Mandarin has just one word for both he and she...
...which is “tā”
So far so good, right?
Not exactly, because in writing they have different characters
Some non-binary people have begun using the Roman letter “X”...
...joined with the Chinese character, or even the Roman letters “TA”
But there is little consensus...
...and many feel that relying on the Roman alphabet...
...is sub-optimal and unnatural
And in other countries non-binary people don’t...
...have it so easy either
French and German, for example...
...like Spanish, have grammatical gender absolutely everywhere...
...but they don’t have such easily available fixes
It may be some time before there are...
...elegant and useable solutions...
...everywhere where non-binary people...
...are seeking greater grammatical visibility